What is the best way to block EMFs in your home?
Well, the best way is to put your entire house in a fair day cage, but that's not really
reasonable, cost-wise.
So it's impossible, that's a joke.
So the truth is you really can't block the EMFs in your home.
So you have to try to mitigate it as well.
And how do you mitigate EMFs in your home?
You look at where are the greatest amount of negative high frequency electromagnetic frequencies
coming from.
The number one thing would be cell towers near your home.
If you live right outside your door is a 5G cell tower.
You are hit with a ton of EMFs that can be highly dangerous.
If I was in the city, let's say, in a large city living in an apartment in a large city
and there was a big cell tower right nearby home, but of course, all of them are 5G now.
Honestly, I would just move.
I would not want to be near that.
Because it can be so detrimental in so many things with your health, not just causing cancer,
but it can affect so many things that have just not been researched or never will be researched.
But okay, so everybody's near a 5G tower, dear enough for you to get a signal.
So what do you do?
Well, you can only do so much.
So then you go, okay, not moving, you know, the 5G tower that I know that I'm near is about
a mile away.
What are the next things that are causing the most EMF radiation in my body?
Well, our Wi-Fi probably is the next thing.
So turn in your Wi-Fi off at night before you go to bed.
You don't need your Wi-Fi on while you're in bed.
Many times you don't need your Wi-Fi on, but maybe an hour a day or I don't know.
So you can just have your Wi-Fi on one of those power strips where you can just turn it
off and turn it back on.
I mean, usually it takes a minute for it to turn back on.
So turning off your Wi-Fi when you're not using it, that would be a real good solution to
help minimize.
Of course, again, you're never bringing this down to zero.
So minimize EMFs.
What's another source of EMFs in your house?
Your cell phone, your cell phone is high about of EMFs.
Even if it's all off, you're still getting EMFs from your cell phone because there's still
communication that's going through your cell phone.
Now, I know I think if you powered it off completely, it's probably pretty low, but you can't
do that.
You know, somebody might want to try to get ahold of you.
So you can't do that.
We're so dependent upon our cell phones, but definitely not using your cell phone up
to your head, using your cell phone.
What you are communicating and making it a call, you're having a speaker phone or you have
a wired connection, you know, to a phone and a wired headphone or use those EMF reducing headphones.
Something like that, you're trying to mitigate it, never charge your cell phone right next
to your band.
That way from you at night, you don't need it right next to you.
You can put it in the bathroom and you turn your ringer up, if somebody's trying to call
you in the middle of it and you'll still hear it, things like that, you're trying to mitigate
things.
And then you get dirty electricity from your own house wiring and there's ways through that
static brand to help mitigate the dirty electricity.
We have the whole house static EMF mitigator on our panel, our electrical panel.
We had to have an electrician put that in, but you can get the plugins at the office.
We have the plugins.
So those are some of the only things you can do.
I mean, otherwise, you know, there we live in a world that there's EMF going through us
all the time.
That's why you have a reception of your telephone.
So you just do the best you can and you leave the results to God like everything else.
So you don't become crazy about this stuff.
You have to know that you're protected.
If you're doing the best you can within reason, you know, God's going to protect you.
You have to just believe that.